il mio obiettivo è arrivare da questo
che un'illustrazione dell'ottocento alla
fine di questo talk a parlarvi del dei
pensieri di prima mattina quando sapete
che dovreste fare un sacco di cose avete
tantissimi buoni propositi però non c'è
la voglia di alzarsi ancora diletto
quindi sarà un bel salto di
immaginazione
però per arrivarci l'immaginazione
proprio la chiave perché durante il
novecento specialmente abbiamo avuto un
sacco di frontiere artistiche nuove che
si sono aperte proprio sul tema
dell'immaginazione e l'idea era che
l'immaginazione umana era infinita
potevamo immaginare veramente di tutto
ma come qualcuno quindi si occupa di
conoscenze potrebbe spiegarmi in realtà
noi utilizziamo cose che ci sono
familiari rimontiamo insieme pezzi per
cui per esempio quando immaginiamo i
draghi oi mostri mitologici usiamo pezzi
di altri animali che abbiamo visto
questa cosa si è ripresentato
ultimamente tutte le volte che
immaginiamo qualcosa di nuovo per
esempio la persona ideale con il ragazzo
quella ragazza che ti fa sognare tutte
le volte quella è montata insieme con
stereotipi e pezzi di altre persone così
sembra un po inquietante nella
nell'immaginarsi altri pianeti e il
resto del sistema solare è successo un
po la stessa cosa questa che vedete è un
illustrazione di un libro di astronomia
di fine ottocento in cui si immaginava
una vista della terra da la luna notate
qualcosa di strano non lo dite è un è un
gioco
questa è un'altra rappresentazione
teatrale che mostrava la terra e la luna
insieme sempre di quell'epoca questa
invece sono le bellissime immagini della
terra ottenute dallo spazio furono
tenute nel 48 da un da un razzo v2 che
normalmente non andava verso l'alto ma
che aveva verso il basso
quindi in questo caso è un uso molto più
nobile però ha scattato le primissime
immagini messe qui a mosaico e notate la
differenza nuvole un sacco di nuvole se
avete mai sentito parlare del pianeta
blu è perché tutti si immaginavano che
fosse blu dallo spazio e piena di acqua
ha senso ovunque guardiamo e blu il
cielo è blu in mare blu sarà blu dallo
spazio
nessuno si era immaginato così tante
nuvole
questa è la terra vista a natale 24
dicembre del 1968 il sessantotto come
qualcuno di voi saprà è stato un anno
complicato non ci furono molti momenti
belli di cui godersi di vista e questo
fu uno di quelli però furono di quelli
che può salvo l'anno da dalle tante cose
tragiche che si videro e questa fu
ottenuta dalla missione apollo 8 la
prima missione che portò degli umani
intorno alla luna
quindi siamo passati dall immagine prima
a questa questa cambiò radicalmente la
nostra cultura e ha cambiato anche la
vita che abbiamo in modi che neanche
immaginate e questo fu uno dei motivi
per cui nacque il movimento
ambientalista
la prima cosa che si vede e d'impatto
sole le nuvole
l'atmosfera il nostro immaginario di
come era fatta la terra fino all'inizio
del novecento era di un mondo pieno di
risorse che non sarebbero mai finite e
che comunque non cambiava niente era un
posto statico era tutto solido duro e
durante sarebbe durato 3 ancora milioni
di anni non c'era niente di cui
preoccuparsi
questo cambia tutto questo invece è
venere venere a un'altra storia molto
interessante perché venere e marte in
realtà è uno dei posti che a noi
sembravano assolutamente misteriosi
rispetto alla terra
tuttavia venere aveva un atmosfera marte
invece cambiava colori per cui tutti
supponevano che magari non ci sono degli
omini che si fanno delle conferenze ted
però forse qualche animaletto magari si
è quindi per fino agli anni trenta
quaranta veniva seriamente presa in
considerazione l'idea che su venere
e su marte ci fossero forme di vita
tant'è che negli anni 40 agli stati
uniti fecero una riunione per capire
come dovrebbero presentarsi dal leader
del mondo a un'eventuale altra specie il
sistema solare perché se ci fosse stata
qualcuno doveva pur parlarli e chi
meglio di degli stati uniti durante la
guerra fredda per dare un'impressione
rassicurante che veniamo in pace questa
bomba non ci fate caso per impressionare
il pubblico e stati uniti tra l'altro in
quegli anni idearono anche un progetto
che doveva lanciare una gigantesca bomba
di idrogeno sulla luna l'idea era che se
avessimo se avessero fatto esplodere una
gigantesca bomba sulla luna e le persone
uscendo proprio nel giardino la sera
avessero visto questa luce si sarebbero
molto entusiasmate avrebbero pensato che
grande nazione che abbiamo o no un
fashion uscire di nascosto la notizia è
sorprendentemente nel pubblico non ebbe
un buon impatto nessuno pensò che fosse
una buona idea e quindi cambiarono è
uscita questo dibattito su cosa fare per
impressionare le persone l'idea che
magari sì ma andiamo delle persone sulla
luna potrebbe entusiasma di più
comunque tornando a vendere venere era
questa era la nostra migliore immagine
di venere non abbiamo la più pallida
idea di come poteva essere non vedevamo
nulla dalla dalla superficie della terra
questa è la prima immagine in alta
risoluzione di venere non è così
entusiasmante come a non poter sembrare
una patata non è non è esattamente il
pianeta
però ci sono delle cose da far notare
l'atmosfera estremamente densa e
talmente densa che sulla superficie
avete 470 gradi centigradi ovunque al
polo nord all'equatore e lo stesso clima
e l'atmosfera è così densa che la
pressione e di oltre il 90 volte quella
terrestre
quindi non è un ambiente molto piacevole
tra l'altro piove al centro storico e se
siete così fortunati da stare sulle
montagne nei vicano metalli o non è un
posto facile dove atterrare immaginate
che immagini potremo ottenere dalla
superficie ok stesso gioco di prima
immaginate per cui il dato il i maggio
l'azione si riutilizza pezzi di cose che
abbiamo familiari vi verrà in mente
un'immagine divennero è tutta strano ma
questo è quello che c'è sotto le nuvole
e ottenuto nei ultravioletti perché i
nostri occhi non sono sto granchè vedono
solo una piccola parte dello spettro il
resto della parte divertenti non le
vediamo questa e della superficie
l'unione sovietica traian settanta e
ottanta portò avanti un progetto
chiamato venera un programma intero di
sonde che sono atterrate su venere e non
non vi dico quanto cuda bambino io avevo
sentito di parlare di queste immagini e
non ho mai avuto alle immagini perché
all'epoca se qualcuno dovesse ricorda
accedere a internet era un'esperienza
molto diversa è una dispensa molto zen
questo e venere invece le rocce che
vedete sono schiacciate dalla pressione
sono pianure di basalti rimasti da
giganteschi vulcani e quello che vedete
nell'angolo e forse qui si vede meglio
sono le stesse di immagini ma quello che
vedete l'angolo e il tramonto su venere
quando quando inizia ad appassionarti
all'astronomia all'esposizione spaziale
ti trovi poi ad entusiasmarsi per cose
che non avresti mai pensato rito
questo invece è marte sorprendentemente
le nostre idee nell'ottocento di marte
non era esattamente dettagliata quelle
linee che vedete erano canali dovevano
essere giganteschi canali con cui una
civiltà su marte trasportava acqua da le
regioni ricche di acqua di ghiacci al
nord fino alle zone dove c'erano le
città un italiano venne fuori con
quest'idea si chiamava schiapparelli e
ed è un sacco di successo nel pubblico
meno di tre gli scienziati però questa
rimase una delle migliori mappe che
avevamo perché continuavano a vedere
macchie scure che si spostavano e
nessuno sapeva cosa poteva essere così
nei anni sessanta abbiamo mandato una
sonda abbiamo mandato una sonda quando
sono arrivati i primi dati a noi anni 60
non c'era ancora non c'erano i
giganteschi computer che elaboravano
tutto velocemente come ora arrivavano
serie uni e dovevamo poi aspettare che i
computer facessero lentamente il loro
lavoro e la traduce essere qualcosa di
più visivo queste sono gli scienziati
del jpl che lavoravano nel 1965 con quei
dati e quelle che vedete sono strisce
con numeri
di un ora loro sapevano che su quei
serie uni c'erano codificati tutti i
dati che erano arrivati da marte quindi
sapevano che 10 e uno in seguenza in
realtà rappresentava qualcosa che
cambiava nella luminosità nella
superficie di marte così impazienti
misero e strisce con numeri e corsero
letteralmente fuori dal set di gpl in un
negozio per bambini uomini grande adulti
in camicia a prendere dei pennarelli e
corsero dietro per iniziare a disegnare
perché non stavano più nella pelle per
mangiarsi come poteva essere davvero
marte tutt ora questo disegno c'è ed è
in un riquadro con con tanto di scale
tutto il resto e quello che vedete
quella parte scura sotto e l'orizzonte
di marte e quella struttura più bianca è
una zona a bassa rigetterà una pianura e
poi ci sono delle zone che somigliano ai
dei cerchi che sono più o meno dei
crateri ora allora giustificazione non è
che non erano bravi a disegnare anche i
dati veri somigliavano qualcosa questa
roba qui non era esattamente ad alta
risoluzione
però si scoprì che marte non ha un bel
nulla di vivo o almeno dall atmosfera da
dallo spazio non sembrava avere niente
celano crateri c'erano pianure è più o
meno tutto qui questa è la nostra una
delle viste migliori e furono tenuti
negli anni 70 quelle zone scure che
continuavano muoversi non erano licheni
o funghi o altre pianure di bisonti
marziani erano semplicemente polvere che
veniva spinta dal vento
questo però è il tramonto su marte e per
darvi un'idea un po più romantica di
questo pianeta perché sembra averlo
maltrattato su marte il tramonto e blu
questa immagine è stata scattata solo
pochi mesi fa da robert curiosi di che
sulla superficie di marte
se non sapete cos'è curioso di male
perché abbiamo su marte ora un nuovo
grande come una macchina che spara laser
dagli occhi a più di venti camere e sta
salendo una montagna grande come il
monte bianco quindi
come vi dicessi se entusiasmo per cose
così per ora non so che lavoro ha fatto
poi alzarsi la mattina e dire io vado a
guidare un robot su marte sport
è un'altra cosa questa invece giove nel
1879 alla nostra miglior immagine e
sembra un mostro è l'immagine vera del
2014 questa tra l'altro per darvi
un'idea di quanto cambiano le cose
l'immagine dello del 79 e contenuta con
il miglior osservatorio che c'era al
mondo quella del 2014 è stata ottenuta
da un nastro fotografo nel suo giardino
quindi ecco tempo passa questi erano
solo puntino che quando avevamo le
immagini come quelli dell'ottocento fino
agli anni settanta ora avesse fatto la
sorpresa per te negli anni 70 era le
lune di giove erano soltanto puntini
nessuno aveva idea di come se fossero
fatte c'erano supposizioni anche l'idv
perché vedevamo la luce riflessa e dalla
luce se lavori abbastanza e perde
abbastanza sonno puoi ricavare degli
indizi su quanta su che tipo di
materiali c'è una superficie per in base
a quanta luce riflette però c'era tutto
quello che potevamo dire abbiamo
scoperto questa roba qui la prima luna
quella gialla di sembra una pizza in
realtà è una luna con oltre 400 vulcani
alcuni di questi lanciano dei pennacchi
giganteschi di lava fino a 30 chilometri
wow quella accanto è una luna che si
chiama europa che sotto tutta la
superficie frastagliata e fatta di
ghiaccio sotto ci sono oceani c'è un
oceano globale altri formante regionali
fatti di acqua liquida c'è più acqua su
quella luna liquida che su tutta la
terra sotto invece il suo tra l'acqua ci
sono probabilmente i vulcani e quindi
forse vita sarebbero europei
le altre due donne si chiamano ganimede
e callisto entrambe hanno una storia
fantastica che qui non posso purtroppo
raccontarvi quella ganimede a 5 oceani
quindi ecco questa era la nostra
migliore immagine di saturno e pensavamo
avesse due giganteschi anelli e invece
così ne ha tantissimi e sono molto
complessi alcuni di questi sono
three dimensional cambiano tantissimo in
spessore se andate in mezzo agli anelli
potete trovare cose che sono grandi
pochi millimetri e cose grandi come
tutto questo teatro e quindi viste così
rendono l'idea ma per darvi l'idea tra
noi e la luna c'entrano tutti gli anelli
di saturno sono molto grande questa è
una luna che non sembra granché vista
così si chiama titano ha un'atmosfera di
azoto ed è l'unico posto del sistema
solare dove le ali di da vinci avrebbero
funzionato perché è molto basso quindi a
una gravità piccola però ha un'atmosfera
molto più densa persino di quella della
terra per cui se ti lanci con delle ali
come quelle di da vinci funzionano
quindi forse la vince sapeva qualcosa
che non sappiamo quelle macchie che
vedete in alto sono laghi c'è un posto
nel sistema solare con fiumi laghi piove
e non è la terra non è londra e titano e
dai piano di laghi di metano liquido
quindi ecco qualcuno di voi sa compagnie
petrolifere
questa è un'altra luna di saturno e
sotto a un oceano gigante ascoltato con
noi pensavamo fosse una palla di
ghiaccio nessuno pensava fosse qualcosa
di interessante poi abbiamo visto questo
quelle che vedete sono rese causati
dalla pressione dell'acqua che spinge
fuori ghiaccio quelli sono cristalli di
ghiaccio provenienti da un oceano
liquido praticamente ci sta lanciando
campioni da portare a casa per per
esaminarli questa è un'altra luna e
purtroppo noi non abbiamo soldi quindi
si chiama già petto e ha una faccia
bianca e una nera indovinate qual è il
suo colore originale ed era coperta del
bianco bianco per tenere non avete fatto
le vostre scommesse
ok e bianca ed è coperta di nera perché
una luna vicina è andata in mille pezzi
e tutta la polvere è caduta sopra quindi
ora si trova con questo lavoro di make
up molto avanguardistico questa invece e
plutone è una nostra migliore immagine
di plutone che nessuno aveva idea di
come fosse fatto plutone e poi siamo
andati a vedere
ve lo ricordate il successo l'anno
scorso
allora se non ve lo ricordate meglio
perché avrete una bella sorpresa
questo è il punto del nostro di del mio
top
noi cerchiamo di immaginarci possiede
sistema solare cerchiamo di immaginarci
tutti i posti ma come cerchiamo di
immaginarci le persone ideale il lavoro
ideale ci immaginiamo la vita ideale e
poi andiamo a vedere andiamo a vivere
andiamo e scopriamo che la nostra
immaginazione si basa sulla nostra
passata esperienza e la realtà ci
sorprende sempre
questo plutone quelle sono pianure di
ghiaccio fatto di metano di azoto e di
acqua la zona più scura per chi di voi è
un amante della letteratura si chiama
tulun regio ufficialmente non so scatta
la col cuore
tra l'altro e l'altro voglio farvi
notare l'idea di plutone perché è stato
è diventato non più un pianeta grande
ufficiale dei pianeti del sistema solare
ma un pianetino nano e quindi se è
probabilmente detto ora mi piace un bel
cuore sopra vediamo su twitter chi ha
più successo ed è pieno di rivas tagga
valori di citazione sono arrivate ci
sono astronomi chiamò a casa pila intere
di lettere di bambini arrabbiati che
plutonio non è più un pianeta il sistema
solare perché sapete quanto tempo ci
vuole quando ai quattro anni a imparare
tutti i nomi del tele dipendenti della
sola e poi arrivi e fa il compito e dice
no questo non è più per età perché con
questa vista questa carrozzi caronte e
la luna ma in realtà non è una luna
perché sono così grandi che il
baricentro del sistema si trova in mezzo
sono molto lontani questi corpi però
hanno una massa che è comunque
globalmente così grande questa luna e
piu di meta di di plutone che orbitano
entrambi in un punto in mezzo quindi in
realtà è l'unico caso il sistema solare
in cui abbiamo un sistema binario cioè
entrambe orbitano in un punto un po più
vicino a plutone rispetto al mezzo
questi mondi sono incredibilmente
sorprendenti e ne abbiamo del sistema
solare
ok non abbiamo idea di come siano fatti
perché la nostra migliore idea di
plutone perché era una palla brillante
di ghiaccio e caronte doveva essere
pieno di crateri fine invece sono sono
venuti fuori cose che non ci sarà lì in
mezzo come vedete col camion gigantesco
quello è due volte più grosso del grand
canyon sulla terra e quella zona scura
sapete cos'è
perché se lo sapete dovresti avvisare la
nasa perché non hanno idea ancora di
casa
quindi c'è un premio per voi solo sapete
ci sono intere montagne più grandi della
jedi dell'everest che sono sprofondate
nel ghiaccio e nessuno sa perché ed è il
bello del dell'esplorazione spaziale è
del tipo l'idea di cui voglio lasciarvi
vediamo se riesco ad arrivare al voi che
è valsa tre mattina l'esplorazione
spaziale ci pone di fronte ai limiti
della nostra immaginazione e ci pone di
fronte all'idea di dover andare oltre e
ci pone anche di fronte ad un'altra cosa
al fatto che per quanto noi lavoriamo a
crearci un immagine di come dovremmo
essere come dovremmo fare le cose come
vorremmo che fosse la nostra vita quando
siete la mattina e sapete che alzarsi
dal letto e andare a fare tutte le cose
belle che dovete fare è un volto novel è
molto importante e tassato solo sapete
lo farete però comunque non è facile
trovare la motivazione interna per farlo
ora immaginate quella con la stessa cosa
paragonate però a generazioni
noi ci troviamo bene oro sulla terra ma
non è detto che tra tre quattro
generazioni sulla terra sistema così
bene visto il cambiamento climatico in
atto
ed è facile dire che alla fine comunque
noi siamo comodi stiamo bene ed è
difficile immaginare qualcosa che non ci
riguarda noi ora subito e basta riguarda
generazioni che verranno dopo di noi ed
è difficile fare questo sforzo
d'immaginazione 6 difficile immaginarsi
darsi la motivazione per alzarsi dal
letto e immaginate riuscire a fare
qualcosa che riguarderà persone che
vivranno quando noi non ci saremo e
l'esplorazione spaziale in questo aiuta
perché ci pone davanti a la meraviglia
ci fa riscoprire quel senso di pura
gioia nel semplice meraviglia
darsi delle cose ed è un gesto che non
ha a che fare con l'utilità non è un non
è che noi scopriamo queste cose perché
faranno diventare nostre macchine più
efficienti subito lo facciamo per la
gioia gigantesca che ci da esplorare ci
fa trovare l'entusiasmo per poi uscirne
dal letto è fare tutte le altre cose ed
è questo spirito di meraviglia verso il
mondo che dovrebbe spingerci anche a
pensare alle generazioni future